the normal and the tangent both pass
through this point that has been
provided in this case it's called t
the difference is
see how the tangent it shares the same
gradient right there the
point of intersection what does the
normal do it doesn't share the same
grading what kind of gradient does it
have yeah
it's perpendicular fantastic so with
your ruler again we don't even know what
the equation is but we can still
actually draw it right go ahead and at
that spot right there
i'm going to do my best i think that's
about 90 degrees
there you go okay pop your rule around
there
and let's draw what the normal should be
this
is what it looks like
and because we've defined it as being
like at right angles there you go that's
important uh as a minor note like why do
we care about normals
normals are really valuable in all kinds
of physical applications so for instance
if you were shining a light or there was
like a radio signal bouncing off of like
a satellite dish or something like that
right
the way it works is that if that
is coming in at a certain angle like so
suppose this is where that radiation was
coming from it's going to bounce off
symmetrically around that normal some of
you might remember angle of incidence
and angle of reflection that's where
this is all about right there's the
angle of incidence there's the angle of
reflection and there's symmetrical
around the normal the normal is like
where everything sort of rotates around
all right now i've got a rough sense of
where it is we want to now try and find
its equation we already know a point it
goes through
how do i find its gradient
okay so we've already got a tension here
right so we've kind of already done half
the work
but the difference is this
remember this guy here
this is the gradient of the tangent
i've anticipated before we'll have a
second gradient so i'm going to say in
fact i'm even going to use this as my my
launch pad right i'm going to say the
gradient of the normal
if it's perpendicular to the gradient of
the
tangent
what happens when you multiply them
together does anyone yeah go ahead
it's negative one yeah very good so
whatever those two numbers are now i've
already got this part the tangent it's
one over e
this is the gradient that i'm after
so what does it look like to you
how am i going to get this by itself
yeah i'm going to multiply both sides by
e right
the gradient of the normal
is equal to negative e now here's why i
asked you to draw that picture
does that look about right
remember e is just a number 2.7 ish does
that look like it has a gradient of
negative 2.7
i'm i'm glad i've got some nods but not
many i'm like come on guys my drawing's
not that bad okay it's decreasing that's
what the negative is about and it's it's
decreasing quite sharply um and that's
why it's a gradient of negative 2.7 from
here we just need to go back into this
point gradient form okay so i'm going to
say
equation of
normal
and in this case i'm going to go a
little bit quicker because they haven't
asked me to prove this
i can get to that working as quickly as
is as my mind can handle basically so
i'm going to go uh y minus 1 equals here
comes the new gradient negative e
and then x minus e like so
and then
i'm just going to put it in the form y
equals uh this will be m x plus b form i
guess minus e x what happens next
when you expand
just watch out for the double negatives
that's going to be
plus e squared that's weird but it's
just a number and then
plus one because that's come from the
left hand side okay
does it make sense
now you can see by the way why i said oh
no i've like run out of space on my
diagram right because you can read off
of this equation as i mentioned before
it's in
mx plus b form right what's the b in mx
plus b
it's the
it's the y intercept right
uh
2.7 ish squared
is something like eight is my guess
plus one is gonna be something like nine
no wonder i've look that that y
coordinate is one so this is going to be
intersecting way up here so i've not
left enough space um oops but you can
see why it's important here have a look
at part c we're ready to go this is the
real question right
sketch the curve done the tangent done
and the normal done
and find the area of the triangle
triangle formed by the y-axis
and our tangent and normal
have you got a picture in your mind i
mean you've got half a picture
if i were to zoom out from this
i imagine it'll look something like this
let me draw it a bit smaller down here
there's my
tangent just use your imagination
and then my normal is going to look
something like that and here
is my triangle do you see the thing
where you're after so i'm going to hit
pause
how do you work out the area of this
triangle what measurements will you use
i'm going to give you some time to try
and work out and there's there's
actually at least three ways that i can
think of for how to work out that answer
so i'd love you to try and work out the
first way
see if you find a different way to the
person next to you if you do the same
way i want you to try and find another
way to calculate the same answer to
confirm whether the answer is what it is
okay
so just review you're doing part c
you're working out the area of this
triangle i want you to do it a couple of
different ways okay if you can do that
as a table if you need to i'll give you
a few minutes to make a head start on me
what i have done because i was
dissatisfied with the two diagrams i
started with i drew a new one and i
noticed that in the question that
they're asking part c it's really all
about this triangle
so while we were initially kind of
focusing on this log x thing to get a
derivative etc
the actual question they're interested
in this
curve is kind of just like a sideshow
right so that's why i've just put it in
dotted it's not that important okay now
the second thing i want to point out is
look closely at the wording of the
question it says
find an area right and then they tell
you where the area is
but notably and i sort of encountered
this around many tables right i can just
see it by how many calculators are out
they've nowhere asked you to approximate
they want an exact answer just like when
you're dealing with circles you end up
with pi
when you deal with exponentials and logs
you end up with e and there's no
escaping it okay so in fact and
calculators will help us to get a rough
sense of like oh that's what the
gradient should look like right but in
terms of finding an exact answer they're
not going to be any use so let's have a
go at this i'm going to show you two
ways to solve it a harder way
and then an easier way okay so have a
look here's the area that i'm interested
in okay
hey mike hold on for me because i will i
do want you to do this have that
conversation just later
when you have a look at the area of this
triangle the first thing that comes to
my mind is often you know like see how
it's like at a funny angle right i can
sort of divide this triangle up into
easier components right so for instance
let's have a look right down here
there's a triangle right in here
that is very very easy to work out its
area let me just call it like triangle
one
triangle one
its area will be half base times height
like all triangles are right now this is
at right angles
and if you look carefully at what
information the question provides you
you already know what the base
and the height are
they're all
right here
e comma one what does that e mean where
is e
on this triangle
it's gonna yeah richie
ah now look carefully be super careful
right
it's 50 50. once the height
one's the base i suppose it depends what
you mean by height right
uh i'm looking at e and it's an
x-coordinate so it actually is a
horizontal distance you okay with that
so that makes this
e do you agree with that
which makes this vertical part here
the height i suppose yeah like you can
turn your head sideways and that'll be
high right but the important thing is
i've got a one i've got an a in fact
because the area is half base times
height it actually doesn't matter which
one's which so i can say it's half
times base times height
like very little actual work required
it's e on two
now i just have to work out this other
triangle right this one up here let's
call this one triangle two now in order
to work out this well i've already got
this which i could call the height or
the base whichever way you want to think
about it i just need to work out this
part
now if you're sneaky you'll realize that
i already told you what that value was i
just didn't tell you that i was telling
you
didn't tell you that i was telling you
that vertical height it's attached to
this um y-intercept right
do you remember us highlighting what
that y-intercept was what was it yeah
keegan
e squared plus one it's right here e
squared plus one now you can see we
already know this is one do you see that
we just sort of highlighted that so that
makes the leftover height this really
tall part it's
e squared
e square
so therefore triangle two what's its
area half base times height again except
it's half
this base times this height
again not very much actual work i mean i
guess i can simplify it half e
cubed so my total area will be
area one area two you can see half is a
common factor and e
is also a common factor so i'm going to
say area
pull that out the front and then what's
left behind is
e squared plus 1 by the looks of things
e squared plus one
now i said i would show you two ways
easy way and a hard way that was the
long way believe it or not there's an
even faster way okay
you saw how i divided this up into two
triangles to make things easier for me i
it was easier to think about
but you don't need to you can work this
out just as a single big triangle
think of e look at it sideways as your
perpendicular height uh rotate your head
that way
can you see it
so this is my perpendicular height and
what i need is this entire thing
as the base
which is
1
plus e squared so therefore its area is
half
that base
which we just said was on plus e squared
times the height which we just said even
though it's sideways is just this eight
and i hope you can see
that's exactly the same deal one line of
working so long as you know what goes
into line of working it's pretty much
done
does that make sense
the fact that it's got like ease in it i
know it's a bit weird but if you've got
a calculator hopefully you can verify
the answer